- The only thing I know about Peru
has to do with llamas and alpacas,
but I really hope you don't eat them
because they're so cute.
- [Man] All of our
knowledge of Peruvian food
is based off of The Emperor's New Groove.
- My dad went to Peru once.
I love pieces of beef.
- Wait, is this llama?
- If this was what the steak
at Chipotle tasted like,
I'd be ordering steak burritos
instead of chicken burritos.
- I like the veggies.
- Ooh, what veggies?
- Look at the veggies.
- You wanna eat onions and the fries?
- I would eat those.
- All the time.
- Breakfast, lunch and dinner.
- Maybe not that, but
I'd eat it a lot, yeah.
- It's like a llama.
- No, it's beef.
- You don't know that, maybe
a llama's made out of beef.
- No, it's not, I do know
that a llama's not made out of beef.
- Have you ever eaten a llama?
- No.
- [Man] This looks like it could have been
from The Emperor's New Groove.
- I'm gonna make a bet that
we're not gonna like this.
- Ooh.
- We could draw our names in it.
- I was immediately going to write Keith,
are you writing Kelsey?
- The sauce, it lingers, like,
I can't get it out of my mouth.
- It probably tastes
like scalloped potato.
- You know that scene in Hook?
Where they, all the kids,
they're playing imaginary
with the food.
This looks like some stuff out of that.
- You always think that that
food's gonna be delicious.
- Yeah, because it's like ice cream.
But this is not ice cream.
- [Man] I feel like a witch made this.
I feel like someone was
like, "Ah, the leg of a crab.
"The tentacle of a squid."
- Yeah, this is finally going
to make that girl I like
fall in love with me.
- The thing I like about this soup.
(she laughs)
Actually, it's not that bad.
- No, it's good, but it's like,
everything from the ocean is in this bowl.
- God, it's terrible.
- It tastes like the ocean tastes.
But deliciouser.
- Smells good, looks good.
- This looks like something
you should have at Halloween.
- It's lighten than jam but
it's thicker than jello.
- I'm thinking about the same rhyme.
- But when it gets in my
mouth, I say, "Hello!"
- Hello!
- Kind of reminds me of the thing
you rub on women's bellies
when they get an ultrasound.
- Like petrolium jelly?
- I think kids would
love this, because like,
it's purple, that's fun.
It's got fruit in it, fruit's awesome,
and it's like sugary,
cinnamony, it's great.
- [Man] Started off really
strong with the beef dish,
loved that.
- Remember the beef dish?
- I miss it.
- It was good, it's like,
some of it was really eclectic
which is interesting, and
some of it was really simple.
- Overall, Peru, yeah you
got food people can eat,
and the seafood is pretty
good, the corn stuff is fine,
the potatoes were confusing,
but overall, I'd eat it.
- I'll give you a solid--
- I'd give it at least a 45.
- Can you see my llama pants?
It it possible to see them?
- You should just, like, lay on the table.
- These are party llamas,
it's why they are dressed in colors.
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh, yeah.
You don't know the half of it.